describe yourself
[Music]
hi I'm Alex and I'm Zoya and today we're
going to be getting creative and
designing our Dream kitchens using the
Sims we both love interior design and
The Sims is the perfect tool to put our
skills to the test okay so my ideal
kitchen is very much like I am as a
person loud and just very like warm and
inviting my ideal style would be like
the opposite of that so kind of just
more dark and Moody industrial modern
minimal I like the like teals and the
greens we've got terracotta like throw
in the colors throw in the pattern maybe
if you can find the cool color maybe we
can compromise I like white you like
wine yeah white it's nice see I don't
like white perfect I love plants I love
the look of plants if you're like me and
you struggle keeping them alive
sometimes fake plants do the job
absolutely not there cannot be anything
worse thing
yeah so maybe like industrial Meats yeah
and warm yeah finding that middle ground
I'm so excited to start this design
process and I really hope that this
kitchen embodies both Zoya and my
personalities we probably have pretty
different ideas of what the kitchen
should look like hopefully there's
enough Common Ground where something
makes sense but we'll see I'm just
really scared she's gonna do something
pink okay I'm so excited for this I used
to play The Sims all the time so this is
bringing back some memories okay I'm
gonna start with some counters my ideal
kitchen style is well organized lots of
storage lots of countertop modern
countertop perfect I cook all the time
there's never enough counter space so
that is a non-negotiable The Moody goth
kitchen of my dreams my ideal kitchen
style is very minimal very clean I don't
like anything out on the counters no
appliances no serving wear I don't want
to really look lived in at all double
fridge double stove I know Zoya will
appreciate that because there is never
Ever Enough fridge space the bar Spark's
a good idea because if I was able to
have a bar in the kitchen I could make
myself drinks while I watch Alex Cook
hot tub wow I think we'll just add
something fun like a hot tub oh
it's perfect wait it's a swim up bar
Zoya better love this design because
she's complaining about fake plants so
now I've given her real trees I want to
do a couple indoor plants real ones not
fake ones wow a mushroom why not you
know what every kitchen needs a bed hear
me out when you get a food coma then you
can just go to bed the guardian of the
nomalexy Alex had like these gnome
looking things when we first met and I
told her she had to get rid of them we
need some gnomes on our mushroom lawn
Zoya would definitely not like gnomes
this just like Zoya as a gnome that's me
as a gnome ooh mannequin of a woman look
at how much Decor I put up that's crazy
guys it's like three things ooh a
mannequin I need one of those there's a
pride flag we need that obviously oh my
gosh guys this is looking amazing Sims
has sparked so many ideas for me to
build a real kitchen I cannot wait to
show zoeia my design she's gonna hate it
it couldn't get any better than this
truly alright I'm about to see your
kitchen
hahaha
what this is a gazebo and a hot tub I
thought you'd like that yeah how do you
know me so well yeah this looks like as
empty as your kitchen was when I met you
yeah perfect this is so good you did a
great job I love the little elements
that you've added and it's not too
modern industrial cold I thought to kind
of warm it up
I'm a very literal oh you definitely
warmed it up yeah for sure I don't know
if we could actually put a hot tub in
the kitchen we design but you know girls
can dream so yeah are you ready to see
my kitchen design no I think it is
exactly what you would expect after we
find out yeah
mushrooms wait is there also a hot tub
where'd you get the palm trees from wait
you have the same bar yes
a bed in case you get a food coma I need
to take a nap what is that thing it's a
cupcake factory wait I have the same
statue
and the fries
our entire world
oh I get bigger but like we have so many
of the same elements not the Gnomes this
is me as a gnome and this is you I don't
know
I really hope we can find a way to merge
our designs and find a middle ground
yeah me too after creating my kitchen
design and showing it to Zoya and then
seeing zoya's design I am really excited
to design a kitchen in real life with
her but also a little apprehensive I
must say let's see how it goes I told
you there'd be gnomes gnomes
I mean her place was really funny and
all that but I know that she does want a
lot of those elements of color and like
we have to find that compromise when it
comes to our kitchen Styles but I I
don't know I guess we'll have to watch
the next episode to find out we hope
this inspired you to get out there and
do something creative and let us know if
any of our ideas have sparked something
in you if you want to show off your
personal Sims kitchen you can download
the game now for free create a whole
world and Spark something with the sense
[Music]